this weekend saw the spectacular
climaxes of two decades spanning epic
series both Game of Thrones and the
marvel cinematic universe culminated in
monumental extravagant clashes for the
fate of their respective universes as
the dust settles on each battlefield the
question remains who staged the best
fight of the weekend though I'm sure
there will be heated debate to my mind
the answer is obvious without a doubt
the best fight with
[Music]
berry I'm serious I saw endgame and the
Battle of Winterfell this weekend and
they're both awesome in their own ways
but the fight that I enjoyed the most
the one that I found the most
interesting was the fight in the latest
episode of Barry called Ronnie slash
Lily's written and directed by Bill
Hader Ronnie slash Lily is essentially
an episode long fight scene similar to
the Battle of Winterfell but with more
sunlight it's engaging from start to
finish and for as absurd as it gets the
plot leads from scene to scene in ways
that make perfect sense that's one of
the things that makes it so great the
story doesn't just feel like it's
advancing but growing from the seeds of
each new moment but I'm getting ahead of
myself the episode begins with something
that's necessary for any good fight
scene a surveying of the battlefield
Hader accomplishes three important
things in the opening shots one he makes
us familiar with the layout of the house
where the fight will take place two he
establishes a ton about this guy's life
without him saying a word and three he
introduces a filming style and tone
these long lethargic camera movements
without any musical score that will
characterize the fight to come the
episode is just 31 minutes and there's a
lot to get through hater doesn't waste a
shot here's one of my favorites again
this establishes the setting which will
pay off later and again we're given
information about Ronnie with just
visuals but now the information is
loaded it's adding tension to the scene
by promising something in the future you
could call this Chekhov's trophy room
and by now the silence is proving more
suspenseful than suspenseful music ever
could as a viewer I'm at the edge of my
seat the fight itself is sloppy but it's
choreographed that way
the signature of Barry is its tone the
way it balances the horrific
consequences of contract killing and the
comedy of it's absurd premise a hitman
who wants to become an actor by
highlighting scenarios that emphasize
both qualities at once
Fred okay four stitches I understand
because the sloppiness of the fight is
hilarious for its sloppiness but that
sloppiness also captures the awkwardness
of violence in a way that makes it feel
real and ultimately painful for the
viewer something I talked about in my
video on Shane black a couple years ago
when violence is real its consequential
so that a single punch to the windpipe
actually determines the direction of the
rest of the episode this is where haters
early work pays off you're not wasting
mental energy on trying to understand
the layout of the space and the camera
movements now in conflict with the
spastic energy of the fight at attention
to the events especially when the fight
moves off screen and the camera is in no
hurry to follow as haider noted in a
Times interview the camera is almost
judging what's happening in other words
the camera has a point of view
figuratively speaking in that same
article hater sites in episode of The
Sopranos called Pine Barrens as a
touchstone for this one Pine Barrens
like Ronnie / lily is a one-off short
story like episode where two characters
get thrust into a surreal nightmare both
episodes pull from and connect to the
larger series but operate on a strange
logic of their own getting increasingly
weirder and more desperate and both
episodes function sort of as a
compressed diamond of the show's major
theme that you're ultimately responsible
for the strange situations that your
choices lead you to Paulie and
Christopher find themselves eating
ketchup packets to survive in the
freezing Pine Barrens of New Jersey as a
direct result of the choices they made
that day but also as an indirect result
of the larger choices that they made for
their lives Barry and Fuchs find
themselves bleeding with their hands
super glued to the steering wheel while
a feral Mongoose child bites and attacks
them for the same direct and indirect
reasons berry killer
so the fightin berry might not be a
fight for the fate of the universe
against all powerful villains with
fantastical powers okay some fantastical
powers but it is a fight that carries a
shitload of
dramatic and thematic wait it's one
that's actually a product of choices and
that in turn makes it genuinely
unpredictable not in the way that a
well-crafted plot is unpredictable but
in the way that life is
with an electric excitement the feeling
that anything can happen next
I'm a fan of big-budget extravagances no
questions but it's kind of awesome to
see that you don't need fifty five
nights of shooting or 55 superheroes to
achieve a thrilling piece of action
filmmaking all you need is a respect for
violence
cinematography with purpose and a vise
grip on tongue oh and Jessie Jekyll
motsi
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching
sorry about the clickbait but I just I
wanted to do a cool surprise so
hopefully you were this episode was
brought to you by Squarespace
if you want to make a website and you
want that process to be just super
simple Squarespace has some beautiful
award-winning designer templates to
choose from it basically does it all for
you it's got 24-hour customer service no
upgrades nothing to install no patches
ever and picking your domain name is
really easy too
you can start your free trial at
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter you can get 10% off your
first purchase before I go I have to
shout out my best friend in the world
Stephen fine who just completed his very
first feature film love shot it's a
low-budget independent movie about a
hitman who falls in love with one of his
targets it's funny it's well acted it's
well directed it's a love letter to the
genre and I am so proud of him for
completing this really huge project it
takes a lot of spirit and grit and love
to create something from scratch and see
it through to the end
all I want from my friends is for them
to succeed and inspire me and you did it
Stephen really I Love You Man and if I
can't shout out my best friends on here
then what's the point so check out
Stephens movie on iTunes or on any one
of the links that I'll leave below in
the description congratulations again
buddy it's an awesome achievement that
was does a great job to be been Bob